- All right guys, so what's up?
Hello, how's it going,
nice to see you today.
We are going, this is a
good wall to shoot on.
This is like one of those
famous Instagram walls.
(pop music plays)
I think it looks good.
Anyway, a super popular thing
on YouTube is product reviews,
like Casey Neistat is one of
my favorite content creators.
He inspired me to make YouTube videos,
and a lot of his videos
are just him reviewing
super cool products.
And I noticed that Buzzfeed
doesn't really do that.
Until now.
Welcome to the first episode of Worth It.
- Worth it. - Worth it.
- That's already a show on Buzzfeed.
So I have to come up
with a different name.
(slapping face)
I got it!
To Buy Or Not To Buy.
Get it, like to...
(sighing)
This is my first ever product review.
I've never done a product review before
because nobody sends me products.
But I decided to take
fate into my own hands.
I emailed a bunch of companies,
I told them I work for Buzzfeed,
and if they send me their products,
I might put them in my video.
So let's go see what I got.
(jaunty music)
What's up man? - What's up, how are you?
- How are you, did I
get a bunch of packages?
- Yes, you got two packages.
(jaunty music)
- Ow, I didn't get that many packages,
but this one is really big,
so it's probably gonna
be something exciting.
Let's go check it out.
(jazzy music)
All right, so I'm gonna start
with the bigger box first.
Need to get scissors.
(jazzy music)
This is gonna big cool, ready?
(ripping)
Wait, all right, and boom.
All right, let's see what's inside.
(dramatic light music)
It's a black box inside of a brown box.
What the (bleep) is this?
It's more box!
There's just more box inside!
Oh my god, I got a Boosted Board,
I got a fricking, "Last Mile
Vehicle," Boosted Board.
(jazzy music)
I just got a Boosted Board.
- (bleep) you, (bleep) you!
- Stop freaking lying!
- This red stripe.
(laughing)
What are you, what are you...
- I can smell your breath.
- Oh my breath, is it bad?
- You need an Altoid.
- Yeah give me an Altoid.
I just got a Boosted Board.
- What's a Boosted Board?
I've never heard of Boosted
Board, ever in my life.
- A Boosted Board is
an electric skateboard,
and according to Casey Neistat
and some other YouTubers,
it is by far the best electric
skateboard on the market.
So let's check it out.
Dude, I am so excited,
I can't believe they
actually sent me a Boosted Board, okay.
I just saw the Boosted Board inside,
and it feels like I'm
inside Casey's video.
Dude, I can't, I'm so
nervous, I'm so nervous,
I don't know why I'm
so excited, all right.
Oh my god!
(rock music)
These wheels are frickin' huge!
It literally looks like the future.
It looks so clean, well
it should be clean,
they just sent it to me.
Whoa, okay, that's heavy,
I'm gonna carry it,
carry it like that.
It's not that heavy, actually.
This is light, now if the
skateboard was this light,
that would be awesome!
There's no instructions.
So I did the research, and
this is the Boosted Plus.
It's basically their newest
classic Boosted Board.
It goes 14 miles, that's how long
it can go on a fully charged battery.
It goes up to 22 miles per hour.
- [Cameraman] Have you
ever been 22 miles an hour
on a skateboard?
- I've never been 22
miles per hour anything.
And it's 17 pounds, so that's not heavy,
it's like a workout, I could be walking
when I'm going to work and stuff,
and I could be curling it, you know?
All right, enough talking, let's
go outside and test it out.
Should I open the other
box, or go out before?
Let me see what's in the
other box, let me see.
(jazzy music)
- [Cameraman] It's like
a Star Wars helmet.
- And what is this?
No (bleep) way!
There's a goggle for
every day of the week!
Rock, this is the best helmet
I've ever seen in my life!
Let's go outside and test it out.
(jazzy music)
I felt comfortable on the
board almost immediately,
and it was really fun.
I'm a quick learner though,
so I let my coworkers test it.
(jazzy music)
It seemed easy for them
too, well for most of them.
(whirring)
- Ah, I can't even stand on it!
(laughing)
(whirring)
God dang it!
Yep I give up, I can't do this thing.
- Whoa!
- The slowest Boosted
Boarder in the world!
In conclusion, for most
people, it's not that hard
to learn how to Boosted
Board, and it's fun!
But is it worth the price?
So this board is $1500,
which is a lot of money.
But I don't have to pay for any
other mode of transportation
anymore, I spend about $200
a month on subways and Ubers.
So if I ride this board
for about seven months,
it's paid off.
An Uber or a subway
usually take me 25 minutes
to get to work, and if there's
traffic or subway issues,
I'm gonna be late.
This board gets me to work in
15 minutes every single time.
So, to buy or not to buy.
I'm going to go with to buy.
(clapping)
So terrible.
(laughing)
Now the video doesn't end here.
If I want to be like Casey,
I gotta ride like Casey.
(laughing)
♪ I don't need recognition ♪
♪ I wanna miss you ♪
♪ I'm paying dues ♪
♪ I'm in position ♪
♪ I'm staying up ♪
♪ And staying late ♪
♪ You're doing good ♪
♪ I'm doing great ♪
♪ Recognition ♪
♪ I'm on a mission ♪
♪ I'm paying dues ♪
I felt ready to ride, so I put on
some triple eight pads and went out.
(dramatic music)
I got this whole Boosted Board thing down,
so you know what, I
challenge you Casey Neistat,
to a Boosted Board race, and if I win,
we become best friends.
Okay, that's a little intense.
And if I win, I am the real Casey Neistat
What?
What's important now
is we need to make sure
Casey Neistat sees this video.
So share it, tweet it,
IG it, beep it, pee it,
do whatever you gotta do.
So what do you say Casey, you wanna race?
(dramatic music)
Casey probably isn't going to
respond to this video, so...
If you just know how to
skateboard, DM me and I'll...
We can have a little race.
(dramatic music)